he sees a message embedded inside that
malware inside that virus that says
leave me here this is his mentor this is
mr. robot this is his awakening and his
call and we have the C storyline finally
well Eliot team up with mr. robot to
prank down the system and Elliott has a
dilemma because as a employee he's there
to get rid of this to root this out but
he decides to leave the message there
because he wants to meet mr. robot and
he says I don't want to leave it I
wanted to stay Willie team up with mr.
robot the question is answered right
from the beginning maybe now act 2 ends
with our first endpoint which is
remember our BM moc story question is is
he going to break down the villain is he
gonna team up with mr. robot to break
down the villain and in the end of our
act we see mr. robot in him on a subway
and mr. Ward says to him I want to break
you out of your present I want you to
work for me and in order for him to do
that though we have a great ticking
clock watch the show mr. robot gets off
the subway and says if you want to work
with me you're gonna do me if you don't
just stay where you are and Elliott sits
and sits and sits and as the doors begin
to close loop he goes through them and
he is gonna be with mr. robot Willie
hook up with mr. robot that's the
c-store line question and it looks like
he is he now goes of mr. robot to Coney
Island to the robots layer and he is
going to see that this what they're all
doing there what all the hackers are
doing there is they are fighting against
the big corporation they're figuring out
a way to beat them but he leaves them
not knowing for sure if he's going to
join them or not and when he gets back
to his apartment we get back to the
beast or line because who is waiting for
him Angela
will he connect with Angela caring and
confidence she says to him I'm glad
you're here do you want to go in and get
high and watch Netflix which we all know
is a bit of a pseudonym she wants to
hook up with him will he he says yes but
when they get inside hell it's drug
dealer and friend with benefits is there
so Angela and Elliott do not connect
this is critical she leaves now he
decides to go back to see mr. robot
again and we're back to the sea
storyline Willie hook up with mr. robot
and here's when mr. robot poses an
irresistible question to Elliot what if
you could take down the one conglomerate
that is the most evil concomitant what
if i told you that this conglomerate is
something that controls all of us
through our debt well that's what Elliot
wants to do more than anything else and
mr. robot says if you get together with
me Elliot we can wipe out the biggest
villain in the world now Elliot doesn't
want to commit now mr. robot says here
here's a here's a data file put it in
the system and it will framed Terry
Colby who we think and he thinks is the
real villain and get rid of him he'll be
thrown out of the corporation Elliot
says but he's just one guy mr. robot
says that's how we start you don't do
this all at once so the invitation has
been given will Elliot stop the big
villains will he team up with mr. robot
will he mr. Robeson see if you do this
you will have said in motion the largest
revolution in the history of the world
now how do we decide a question like
that with a montage because the hero
goes away says I don't know about this
we hear Neil diamonds if you go away
play as we see him thinking as he walks
down the subway is he going to do this
will Elliot find and stop the real
villains and we're at our second end
point where at the end of the third act
it looks like he's going to maybe do it
we don't know Elliot's thinking about it
and we see him go
line and check Angela's debt Angelo's
two hundred thousand dollars in student
debt will he help her he could but guess
what Elliott decides not to do it this
is now the fourth act were headed for in
the fourth act both the low points of
the hero and also a high point of view
it all happens an act for the obstacle
point which is the moment when he seems
to fail and the climax when he seems
finally to succeed Ellie decides not to
frame the villain so the next day he
goes back in and they meet and they meet
with the big fat apparent villain and he
says to them ok so did you find out why
we got hacked or not
you